hello everyone and welcome back to the
global chess League we have one of the
greatest matches or rather one of the
greatest rivalries uh there ever were in
chess there is the Magnus Carlsen versus
at the moment they are both a former uh
video classical Champions uh even though
this is a rapid game uh this is their
their first encounter is both um have
lost their affiliate classical title but
Magnus is still the world rapid Champion
uh so there's that and uh he won the
world rapid Championship four times and
also won the world to Rapid Championship
he won it twice in 2017 uh and also in
2003 already 20 years ago he defeated a
democratic in the finals um uh so I mean
of course it will be an incredible fight
one could imagine in the uh interview
after the game they asked the players
you know how do they still feel about
playing each other and they said that
they played so many games uh after the
World Series championship match that um
you know it's not as special to them as
it to the audience but I'm sure you guys
are always excited when Magnus is
playing Anand and I am as well so let's
check it out Magnus has the white pieces
and he plays Pawn to see for he goes for
the English opening upon the C5 and the
G3 uh the well uh probably go planning
to go for some sort of a symmetrical
setup Knight to C6 with Bishop to G to
end up onto G6 and also preparing to
think of his dark Square Bishop Knight
to C3 and Bishop to G7 the so-called
Ultra symmetrical line D3 we have D6 and
now uh there are some games where E3 was
played also Knight H3 is a known move
but here we have Queen to D2 by Magnus
and it is now ass of move six that we
have a completely new game so okay Anand
continues development Knight to F6 with
B3 now preparing to pincare to the other
Bishop as well castles and Bishop to B2
and while this is all very nice and
you're probably wondering why doesn't
everyone just do this every game I mean
aren't The Bishop's best deployed on the
longest diagonals possible yes but it's
often very easy to counter them so here
Bishop to D7 Knight to F3 and now Rook
the B8 preparing to push that pawn to B5
uh we have castles and of course A6
preparing Pawn to B5 we have Knight to
D5 by Magnus now putting pressure on F6
also opening up his dark Square bishop
and here Anand played Pawn to E6 later
in an interview after the game he said
that it was sort of a uh well a weird
moment for him because he he wanted to
play E5 he knew that E5 was probably
best it closes the position and uh not a
lot to hope for here doesn't look like
much for either of them let's say if
something like E3 you can play B5 and so
on and so on but it's not a very
interesting so instead he played Pawn to
E6 which
aims to trade off a lot of pieces uh and
then perhaps later on Advance the Ponto
D5 or E5 so okay Knight captures on F6
checked by Magnus with Bishop captures
and now Pawn to D4 uh later in an
interview after the game Magnus said at
this point to D4 was uh a key move for
him to to play because they finally
played Pawn to E5 instead of Pawn to E6
D4 would not be possible so okay Pawn to
B5 and now Magnus plays D captures on C5
Bishop captures on B2 Queen captures and
of course the captors on C5 and now uh
you might be thinking well uh Magnus uh
of course plays the C captures on B5 we
have eight characters on B5 and Rook
after C1 and now this well would or
should be a weak backward spawn uh
because you can never play C4 but it's
not because the queen is on the same
file as the rook and Anand uses this to
his Advantage he plays Spawn to C4 B
characters B counter is now opened an
attack towards magnus's Queen but just
Queen to C3 and now as you can see it is
impossible to defend the C4 Pawn so
Magnus will win it so Pawn to E5
uh with ideas that if Magnus goes after
the E5 Pawn instead of the sc4 pawn then
Arnold will get his Rook to E8 go after
D2 Pawn uh get even more activity so
Magnus simply captures the C4 pawn and
now Queen to E7 we have Pawn to H4 and
Rook F to C8 nicely uh deploying the
Rooks on the on the CNB file now some
maybe nasty discoveries will be possible
but Magnus just moves the queen you
could trade Queens right away with Queen
to C5 but Magnus feels that the queen
has a more used
um than just a training her for for the
black queen uh so you stop onto E4 but
Anand will of course not allow that he
plays the ship the F5 kicks away
magnus's queen queen to E3 and now Pawn
to E4 uh attacks the Knight Knight the
G5 uh and now Knights the B4 there is no
way to defend the pawn uh and Aaron
knows it we have Rook captures on C8
here okay if you go after the pawn right
away then anand's plan was real
characters and then maybe the Knight can
pick off the A2 Pawn but Magnus just
captures it Rook captures and see it
with check Rook counters and Bishop
captures on e4 now so what was anan's
real plan with Knight to B4 uh well it
was Knight the C2 attacking the queen
and the rook and now Magnus has to go
for this end game which is better for
him uh it's all merely a matter of how
better how much better
uh so Bishop captures on C2 Queen
characters on E3 with f characters and
Rook captures and C uh C2 now Magnus is
up two pawns but uh Anna's position is
very active he has a bishop against
tonight The Rook is already on the
second rank uh this will be very very
hard to win Magnus plays King to F1
defends the pawn and now just Bishop to
C8 now he wants to play Bishop to A6 and
go after this E2 pawn and remember after
that game five where Magnus Carlson
defeated vishwanathan in their 2013
World Church championship match uh they
asked Gary Kasparov about his thoughts
after the game and he said that famous
saying that you know in the end game the
gods have placed Carlson so uh are the
Gods uh you know do the God still favor
a Magnus uh let's check out how the game
went we have Knight to F3 uh and now
Bishop A6 of course going after D2 Pawn
but now just Knight to D4 you know you
don't have to worry about the YouTube on
the Knight is not nicely defending the
DuPont and of course the Knight is on a
dark Square so you can never kick it
away you only have a rook and a light
Square Bishop so Rook the C3 and also
that very nicely uses his Rook he
attacks the E3 Pawn uh so Magnus has to
defend the pawn and then he will shift
The Rook over to A3 and prevent Magnus
from uh advancing his a pawn so King F2
and of course Rook to A3 now with ideas
of Bishop C4 and winning that A2 pawn
and now okay Max would still be up one
Pawn but it would be a double D pawn and
that would be a draw so Knights the C2
attacks The Rook with Rook the A4 and
now Pawn to A3 it's on a dark Square so
it's a very safe uh Magnus uh now has to
figure out how to kick the Rook away
from A4 some moves with the Knight put
the Knight on B2 kick away the rook and
then Advance the pawn to A4 and A5 and
so on and repeat that until the pawn
reaches A8 so here we have Bishop to B7
and Knight to B4 we have King to G7 uh
here you could also consider a bishop to
E4 it prevents the knight from going to
C2 but uh if you play something like a
knight to the D3 for example uh going
for Knight to C5 to attack the bush
A5 you could play A4 it's not a problem
and then if the bishop attacks the pawn
then you go back Knight to the B2 and
then you figure out a way now I probably
just use the dark squares get the king
all the way to B4 kick away The Rook uh
and play A5 A6 and so on
so after night the B4 uh Anand instead
decided to activate the king king to G7
was played and now Knight to D3 we have
rooked A5 and Rook to B1 now you were
probably expecting Monte A4 but Magnus
has a different plan attacks the the
bishop here and now Bishop to D5
probably the plan was if a bishop to E4
let's say then uh he could play Rook to
B4 and maybe if Anand tried to win a
pawn here let's say Bishop captures e
captures and Rook captures on A3 uh then
Magnus plays D4 he undoubled his pawns
and now the D4 Pawn is extremely strong
uh but Anand doesn't go for Bishop T4 he
plays Bishop to D5 and now just Rook
back to A1 so probably his plan didn't
work out with Bishop T4 now and Knight
to B2 now preparing Ponte A4 and now
King to H6 with Knight to the C4 uh
kicks away The Rook Rook to A6 and pawn
to A4 so you want to have your knight
ready to advance the pawn all the way to
A5 and again yeah if you play Bishop the
D5 then just Knight back to B2 and now a
rook A5 you do stop at the pawn but it's
uh uh it's a it's a fairly similar
position and you might even you know run
into some E4 moves uh for example Pawn
to E4 and I have Bishop captures any
Fortnight the C4 uh also you you win
some squares okay you get rid of your
past Pawn uh not pass Pawn doubled Pawn
uh but you get rid of The Rook you play
A5 A6 and so on and also you could try
just bringing the king into the game uh
also uh could be could be very nice but
instead after A4 Anand played King the
H5 and now we have Knight to D2 attacks
the bishop and now Rook the F6 with
check again if you repeat with Knight to
D5 it's uh the same thing font A5 and I
spawn to F5 stopping Ponte for you will
go Knight to F3 and then the Knight
again
uh will uh find its way uh over to the
pawn for example if King to H6 Knights
the D4 will happen if King G7 Knights
the C2 and then of course if Bishop to
E4 uh Knights the B4 kicks away the
Rogue Rook to A7 and then again the king
comes into the game via the dark Square
spawn will come to A6 A7 uh and so on of
course A6 then the Knight will somehow
kick away The Rook or or the king might
come all the way to be six take away the
rook and then uh we advance the pawn to
A7 which is a dark square and then uh
well good things will happen so instead
after Knight D2 We have Rook to F6 check
by which Knight to F3 and now King to G4
uh and here Magnus played Ponte A5 and
he was in this position on move 44 that
vishwanathan Anand resigned the game as
there seems to be nothing more to be
done here so it could be a bit premature
on and had over a minute on the clock
magnets at over two minutes uh but uh I
mean if if a former world champion uh
former world class and former World
rapid Champion decides that it's time to
call it a day then you you well one
tends to to believe him and of course uh
you can if you want to check for sure
you cannot because chess has only been
sold for up to seven pieces on the board
which means and in this case a piece is
yes a rook upon and the King those are
all pieces and here you have um uh
that's four that's six eight ten uh 12
14. 14 pieces uh just it's gonna be a
very long time before we solve chess for
up to 14 pieces on the board uh I've
read somewhere that they are currently
solving chess for up to eight pieces on
the board but I mean no one can even
guess when that will be but up to seven
pieces yes it has been solved
uh so you know we we cannot uh know for
sure uh but we can ask our good friend
the engine and this yes uh of course is
winning the problem is how are you
stopping the pawn if you play something
like Rook day six okay you've stopped
the pawn but then Knight G5 attacks both
of the pawns attacks the bishop and uh I
mean you're gonna lose another pawn and
then it's very much winning and the
other thing is that if you don't uh okay
you could maybe I'll let the pawn come
to A6 but then you what are you gonna
play play King to F5 then we play Pawn
day six then Rook to B6 uh Pawn to A7
and then Bishop to A8 the only way to
stop the pawn from queening uh but now
again Knight G5 and you will lose more
pawns and then the game if you try
something like F6 uh sort of a trick to
take away the G5 Square from the Knight
and maybe try to win the Knight later on
let's say Knight captures an H7 Rook B7
uh it will not work because there's a
rook the eighth I would check and now
the king either moves away and then
Knight captures an F6 happens or you try
to save the pawn and then Rook a 6 check
again will win the F6 Pawn because now
The Rook also guards uh the the Knight
so that's a problem so I A5 is uh okay
it could look maybe a bit premature
because Anand had more time on the clock
but like I said if Anand resigns then
you can be sure it is not premature uh
so yeah uh very nicely done by Magnus
like I said their first game as both of
them now are uh former World classical
Champion so you know there is some
significance to that I believe so hope
you enjoyed that I would like to thank
Brian Baker bullet justreuler.com Samuel
Kane Dan McCormick and James Eugene
Cashman for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and yes I have um I I forgot
to show you the standings so here are
the standings not the standings but the
results of the of the big clash between
these two teams uh there you have it
even though a Magnus defeated on an on
board one uh his team the Alpine
Warriors have lost uh the game to to
Genji's Grand Masters as a rapper
defeated gookish on board 2 and kotanist
really defeated pets on on board five uh
so there we have it very nicely done by
anan's team uh you know he lost about
his team won so you know there's also
that uh see you soon have an excellent
rest of your day uh enjoy